this episode was brought to you by the
waffle Association of America most
important the other day actually that
probably not true they're saying I don't
care if you're the most important meal
of the day
uh look uh and now has power over all of
breakfast simple as it has the power of
breakfast I don't know it's definitely
power in breakfast yeah somehow it's a
Power View uh supplying together
breakfast monster this is together
breakfast ah can do whatever it wants
so whatever it wants to be this fucking
show now I want to go to a Waffle House
do not not like the Florida waffle
houses are like a real waffle oh I went
there oh you people love Waffle House
Bailey oh my god now Florida is gonna be
so pissed at you I just want waffles are
a little thicker than you know they're
like America's / they're like America's
Wang dude you don't want your Wang upset
at you um thanks for putting that
thought in my head um but apologies to
America's Wang uh this is an episode
where Stephen makes this together
breakfast with so various Americas Wang
does that mean la is like America's
asshole sweet so we know row mound is
the armpit of America's when we always
come I would say that's Jersey that
whole New York areas we're just gonna
make fun of every state egg boy this
emoji for ours yes ours is awesome even
though the weather sucks it's really
corrupt in there's construction like
24/7 beside from that we kick ass can we
get back to the waffles please yes
that's clear the most important thing
here so he makes this breakfast with
this very carefully laid down strawberry
the dub strawberry uh and he was to
share with those three friends mothers I
don't know I
this episode was very much Stephen his
three neglectful mommies yeah it's like
I still don't know a value brought up to
I'm like does this kid go to school it's
like apparently God is like why doesn't
the father with it there's like all
these questions are they my friends are
they like lesbians in a relation what if
I my parents I mean yeah it's never it
has happened spelled out yet I mean it
kind of the woman it's that 21st century
whatever you want to do is fine just
tell me what it is how it's going on but
I guess it's like full house gender swap
ish I mean oh that's a good point
uh except but I think we're we were
pretty sure that Joey was gay though
right
oh we weren't sure we were positive okay
I'll check um but yeah so he makes this
together breakfast he wants to share
with them but they're Ellie's uh alright
it's nice yeah my my favorite moment is
when garnet shows up on that transporter
device and it's just her and I don't
know where I just really wanted her to
say like the others are all dead I guess
you and me your two mothers cannot be
with you anymore because she just showed
up and I was like where's the other two
and I'm like oh my god maybe they didn't
come back so she goes to uh I guess for
a room part of the temple yeah just by
the temple and uh pearl and amethyst
so you seen amethyst amethyst oh my god
that'll the one I can tell Maya some
rocks Grampa all right was it again
amethyst amethyst and the fist okay uh
we kind of see there was one ice kind of
we gonna miss amethyst amethyst pethau
um so we go into their rooms and that
they're kind of cool they're like pearls
especially I thought was really neat
they're sort of like Jesse's pools of
water that dripped down I like
waterfalls and they she's got like a
lady lake thing going we're like these
Excalibur swords come on
um and Steven just once you breakfast
with them but like it cuz hers is like
the most kind of like pretty girly Fey
but she's got swords come out of fucking
water I'm like nice necessarily garages
are very peaceful I just felt like
wrecking I could sleep in that room that
just be away it's very nice spa pond
yeah the lake
um yeah where is the amethyst is very
much kind of like a junk heap and
argit's is just very boring you know
yeah like a volcano where she burns her
soul alive as it as she had that weird
piece of paper like I just lamp because
of the random darkness because she's
like I would have to burn this and it
takes the cell phone and this too and
then when she burns it it like screams
like ah yeah it's not sound like enough
what the fuck I suppose if I could think
she just burned somebody's soul and it
infests infects the breakfast the
breakfast comes alive tries to kill them
but they stop it and then the kid eat
breakfast cuz part of this R is a
complete breakfast yes uh rific ly
complete breakfast and then one of funny
your ending lives we see we're a PC yeah
yeah we had a ditch tried to kill us
so deadpan uh I mean I like her the most
so I mean a few things we've learned to
add to the list of things that we wear
in every episode one the gems in the
belly in his belly he tries to use to
open the door didn't quite work there
seems to be three parts of the temple
the temple has a crystal heart it seems
to me I don't want this example well
yeah like a combination between it's
like it's like this bottomless pit
there's like five bottomless pits in the
play it's like a combination between
like a super mario world level a barbie
doll house the Temple of Doom and Hill
House and a spa and a spy yeah um it's
just it's very random that has a crystal
heart um yeah I enjoy exploring the
temple that I will see the one thing
that and this is not even like a crack
against the show this is more just me
there is so much you see them doing that
I'm sure
either they're going to explain later or
it's just like oh you're kind of not
supposed to know that tries me not so
like what the hell is that sheet of
paper and the writings out there and the
smoke that came out of it in practice I
actually found it much more enjoyable
that knowing I know I'm loyal that's not
a risk I probably just think somebody's
a mortal soul in like the volcano room
but I mean all the other things like why
doesn't he go to school who the fuck are
these women really I mean I'm assuming
they're like a cousin of Temple Doom but
way more hilarious if you just see mol
Rob told me pull that guy's heart out I
won't come on then Jones like girl never
goes back there again and it's never
reference you see what I'm actually you
know I wait to make monkey brains for
this I ain't shorty fuck this shit we
get out of here Phyllis believed Willie
Shaggy sacrified will be a great how it
should have ended for temple and dude
they just see the heart he just goes
nope exactly like Alana in Archer know
just knew kill see here support a group
I got a gun I'm gonna tell them to make
that sis a doctor in a while that'll
just be hey can you do this y'all give
me credit didn't make it cuz I want to
see it I just love to see Harrison Ford
to see that artsy just go Oh adventure
totally avoided this so um Eddie are we
talking about together breakfast uh yeah
like it was it was fun seeing the the
temple um yeah even stuff it's just fine
cuz there's things I'm realizing that I
haven't questioned if I really should
cause you like you know what the fuck is
that temple why is it shaped like this
person holding out a hand you wanted to
help it's a temple cuz on the outside
there's like a statue but like these
leaders are going five arms and but it's
like just what is it just there's all
these questions that I guess they both
annoy me and intrigue me at the same
time there's probably a few too many for
me like Adventure Time even though
there's a lot of questions a lot of
still on answering stuff it's still like
the episode for the most part you get
the gist Finn and Jake are two guys who
go out and life isn't always about
answering questions I know and iris
for that it drives me nuts sometimes me
done miss - there's a there's a bit too
much mystery for me for now even though
I know they're gonna like answer stuff
and everything but yeah but it's still
fun and the animation skis back on track
and now the animation seems kind of like
what it was the other episodes we saw
how these different Stephen looks goofy
and I get that like the first time you
introduces the breakfast account looks
like his eyes are almost like a Picasso
or whatever buddy so that kid from the
critic yeah Jay Sherman's son like Eddie
there's certain times where I'm just
like and watching it in like all I see
did he employ our girlfriend to dindi it
what happened somebody showed a picture
that showed like ma Sherman's kid and
then like this other girl I'm ready
episode my camera she was Indian or what
I don't know but it if this other girls
Indian ivory and she is ideas but that's
all I see is the same kid just with a
star and as a that's fine that's fine it
just makes me laugh because I want to
see Jay Sherman come out like I thought
maybe much no I think our bundles going
on here sure man somebody post on my
facebook like the Jay Sherman with the
girl I swear she looks Indian a baby and
maybe he's not but I'm aliens a guy my
Jess so um no it was fun it was fun sort
of going to this fun house hi this weird
temple and doing stuff I think just
temple of cute dude well let's go st.
doing stuff I think kids would just like
to see you know the character to slide
down poles and walk upside down Joe
Budden oh this princess
oh um but yeah I guess again it's kinda
hard to count in a lot because I just I
don't know what a lot of stuff is but
it's uh still interested in creative and
now we want waffles
yes Jim you Steven universe they are
like in my grocery list like every
single time I watch us two of these is
gonna be like nothing but other like you
know ice cream sandwiches waffles
cheeseburger um cash fingers which we
should mention that this review is now
like twelve hours later because we've
been marathon in Super Mario World
Rihanna maybe uh and
yeah I want chocolate after that because
they have like the chocolate eyelids and
stuff and turtle soup cuz you know it's
that kind of goes without saying I Wow
are there like an endangered species or
something oh I don't care I've been
jumping out of for hours so Wow
kill your own turtles I should probably
change our clothes since we've been
doing yeah um I must melt bad you do you
smell like that many roses either no but
I smell like a few roses you do I thank
you how do you get that hmm the rose
smell the few roses it's mostly pig ass
but then it's like a few roses in there
too well you eat them along with pork
I'll remember or you could eat a rose
fed pig why would you do that to smell
like this good answer
who